what does Mariah Carey want her
billionaire ex-fiance to apologize for
and that's not all she was breaking up
with Mariah comes with an inconvenience
I'm still always gonna be a diva in
certain ways like why not just be
yourself hashtag the diva let's just get
this straight they weren't married there
was no sign prenup and no sex before
marriage so what exactly is involved in
Mariah's 50 million dollar inconvenience
fee well there's that engagement ring
estimated at 10 mil she wants James
Packer to buy her an LA home somewhat
similar to the one they're renting for
250 K a month and the rest may be once
paid out in cash mariah claims the
billionaire owes her and here's your
list of wise one quote he made promises
to her that weren't fulfilled - he moved
her cross-country and relocated her and
the kids
now the 46 year old would like James to
apologize for breaking up with her so
publicly you heard that right rife is
used for her fame James quote used her
to increase his profile to help further
his business interests what'd it say I
wasn't like on the prowl and I was like
oh this guy's really fun this uh.this it
was nice
our source tells us James is the one who
waived the prenup because he'd loved her
so much and wanted to make her happy
that included letting Mariah plan
multiple weddings there was a March
ceremony planned in Bora Bora a wedding
gown by Valentino couture and even a
mini version made from Monroe they're my
kids they'll always be with me and at
these Affairs miss Monroe has her own
dress that she's been making as for
James's side of the story a source tells
us quote this whole 50 million dollar
thing and other noise is a distraction
to try and rationalize what Mariah is
asking for
you